can we try to Define AGI that would be
mentioning how do you like to think
about what artificial general
intelligence is or super intelligence or
that is there a line is it a gray area
is there a good definition for you well
if you look at humans humans have
significantly more generally applicable
intelligence compared to their closest
relatives the chimpanzees well closest
living relatives rather
and a b builds highs the beaver builds
dams a human will look at a B Hive and a
beaver's dam and be like oh like can I
build a hive without a honeycomb
structure I don't like hexagonal tiles
and we will do this even though at no
point during our
ancestry was any human optimized to
build hexagonal dams or to take a more
clear-cut case we can go to the Moon
there's a sense in which we were on a
sufficiently deep level optimized to do
things like going to the Moon because if
you generalize sufficiently far and
sufficiently deeply chipping Flint hand
axes
and outwitting your fellow humans is you
know
basically the same problem as going to
the moon and you optimize hard enough
for chipping Flint hand axes and
throwing Spears and above all outwitting
your fellow humans in tribal politics
uh you know the the the the the
skills you entrain that way if they run
deep enough
let you go to the Moon
even though none of your ancestors like
tried repeatedly to fly to the moon and
like got further each time and the ones
who got further each time had more kids
no it's not an ancestral problem it's
just that the ancestral problems
generalize far enough
so this is Humanity's significantly more
generally applicable intelligence
is there
a way to measure
general intelligence
I mean I could ask that question a
million ways but basically
is will you know it when you see it
it being in an AGI system
if you boil a frog gradually enough if
you zoom in far enough it's always hard
to tell around the edges gpt4 people are
saying right now like this looks to us
like a spark of general intelligence it
is like able to do all these things it
was not explicitly optimized for yeah
other people are being like no it's too
early it's like like 50 years off and
you know if they say that they're kind
of whack because how could they possibly
know that even if it were true
um
but uh but you know not to strum in some
of people may say like that's not
general intelligence and not furthermore
append it's 50 years off
um
or they may be like it's only a very
tiny amount
and you know the thing I would worry
about is that if this is how things are
scaling then jumping out ahead and
trying not to be wrong in the same way
that I've been wrong before maybe GPT 5
is more unambiguously a general
intelligence and maybe that is getting
to a point where it is like even harder
to turn back not that would be easy to
turn back now but you know maybe if you
let if you like start integrating gpt5
and the economy it is even harder to
turn back past there
isn't it possible that there's a you
know with a frog metaphor you can kiss
the Frog and it turns into a prince as
you're boiling it could there be a phase
shift in the Frog where unambiguously as
you're saying I was expecting more of
that I was I was I am like the the fact
that gpt4 is like kind of on the
threshold in either here nor there
like that itself is like
not the sort of thing that is not quite
how I expected it to play out
I was expecting there to be more of an
issue uh more of a sense of like like
different discoveries like the discovery
of Transformers
where you would stack them up and there
would be like a final Discovery and then
you would like get something that was
like more clearly general intelligence
so the the way that you are like taking
what is probably basically the same
architecture is in gpt3 and throwing 20
times as much computed it
probably and getting out gbt4 and then
it's like maybe just barely a general
intelligence or like a narrow general
intelligence or you know something we
don't really have the words for
um
yeah that is uh that's not quite how I
expected it to play out but this middle
what appears to be this Middle Ground
could nevertheless be actually a big
leap from gpt3
that's definitely a big leap from gpt3
and then maybe we're another one big
leap away from something that's that's a
phase shift and also something that uh
Sam Altman said
and you've written about this is
fascinating which is the thing that
happened with gpt4 that I guess they
don't describe in papers is that they
have like hundreds if not thousands of
little hacks
that improve the system you've written
about value versus sigmoid for example
a function inside neural networks it's
like this silly little function
difference
that makes a big difference I mean we do
actually understand why the relatives
make a big difference compared to
sigmoids but yes they're probably using
like
g4789 Ellis and or you know whatever the
acronyms are up to now rather than relus
um yeah that's that's just part yeah
that's part of the modern Paradigm of
alchemy you take your time to heap of
linear algebra and you stir it and it
works a little bit better and you stir
it this way and it works a little bit
worse and you like throw out that change
and yeah
but there's some simple
breakthroughs
that are definitive
jumps in performance like regulars over
sigmoids and uh in terms of robustness
in terms of you know in all kinds of
measures and like those Stack Up
and they can it's possible that some of
them
could be a non-linear jumping
performance right
Transformers are the main thing like
that and various people are now saying
like well if you throw enough compute
rnns can do it if you throw enough
compute dense networks can do it and
not quite a GPT before scale
um it is possible that like all these
little tweaks are things that like save
them a factor of three total on
computing power and you could get the
same performance by throwing three times
as much compute without all the little
tweaks
but the part where it's like running on
so there's a question of like is there
anything in gpt4 that is like kind of
qualitative shift that Transformers were
yeah over
um rnns
and if they have anything like that they
should not say it
if Sam Alton was it was dropping hints
about that he shouldn't have dropped
hints
so you you have a that's an interesting
question so with a bit of Lesson by Rich
Sutton
maybe a lot of it is just
a lot of the hacks are just temporary
jumps and performance that would be
achieved anyway
with the nearly exponential growth of
compute
a performance of compute
compute being broadly defined do you
still think that Moore's Law continues
Moore's Law broadly defined the
performance is not a specialist in the
circuitry I certainly like pray that
Moore's Law runs as slowly as possible
and if it broke down completely tomorrow
I would dance through this to the
streets singing Hallelujah as soon as
the news were announced
only not literally because you know
you're singing voice oh okay
I thought you meant you don't have an
Angelic Voice singing voice